chers amis samedi à commencer par un bon
vieux chers amis on est en période de
virus en ce moment que quand on a des
russes qui s'empêchent de partout ça
vous le savez est justement il faut
faire attention au geste sanitaire qu'on
va avoir pour éviter de propager le
virus
justement dans tout ça on a juste là il
faut faire gaffe à ça ça c'est à la fois
votre meilleur ami votre pire ennemi par
rapport aux grosses pourquoi parce qu'on
est tous tout le temps sans nos
smartphones a navigué à tenir bien
évidemment avec sa main d'un côté avec
son pouce pour rien naviguer ou
carrément avec seedorf est ce que vous
voulez après avec vos doigts sur votre
smartphone ça vous regarde ça ne regarde
plus mais par contre il faut faire
vachement gaffe parce que ça ça véhicule
beaucoup de bactéries savait qu des
virus avait culpable de choses alors pas
nécessairement le coronavirus si vous
n'avez pas été en contact avec lui mais
malgré tout c'est un vrai nid à microbes
il faut donc le nettoyer et aujourd'hui
encore plus qu'il ya si vous ne le
faisais pas hier eh bien vous faisiez
votre immunité grâce à ça je vous parle
aujourd'hui le smartphone les par
extension appareils de tous les objets
technologiques que vous allez avoir être
vous allez toucher en intérieur mais
également l'extérieur les ordinateurs
portables les bugs les écouteurs tout ce
que vous allez trimballer avec vous
touchez avec des mains qui sont
potentiellement salle je suis donc
aujourd'hui vous dire ce qu'il ne faut
pas faire déjà dans un premier temps ce
qu'il faut pas utilisé comme produit il
est normal de fond derrière ce qu'il
faut pas utiliser ce qu'il faut faire ce
qu'il faut utiliser de quelle manière
faire et qu'elle un petit peu la
solution idéale pour lutter justement
contre aujourd'hui le coronavirus mais
ça peut être la grippe demain ça peut
être la gastro entérite ça peut être pas
mal de choses et ces gestes qui valent
aujourd'hui en période de crise voudront
tout le temps donc pour le coup ça peut
être pas mal de le savoir
classiquement chez nous on a quand même
pas mal de produits ménagers on peut se
faire au prix de tabourets vraiment que
je change sur m toujours un peu de bruit
de fond l'advanced idiot ben c'est un
peu le dj du studio classiquement chez
nous on a beaucoup de produits et ils
sont pas forcément tous adaptés à
nettoyer un smartphone ça c'est pour
nettoyer les glaces ça c'est pour
nettoyer la maison avec ou sans gel
et puis en ce moment on a aussi un
produit qu'on a tous chez nous porte et
qu'on peut réussir en avoir ici c'est la
news gel ça vous permet de désinfecter
vos mains de les nettoyer et aussi toute
la question des différentes l'âge est
multi surfaces et compagnie on a
différents types de tissus dans tout ça
c'est souvent compliqué de savoir
exactement ce qu'il faut utiliser ce
qu'il faut pas utiliser mais je suis
pour des brûlures l'histoire alors
regardez c'est très très très simple
venez pas la toute première chose c'est
bien que ce smartphone est
ratification ip68 il pèse 67 pour la
plupart pas tous mais pour la plupart ça
les protège contre l'eau et la poussière
ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils vont être
étant que si vous les immergé pendant
une longue période peut potentiellement
les abîmer d'ailleurs il faut savoir que
lorsque vous les tremper vous les
immerger et si toutefois un problème
arrivait à la suite de ça et bien votre
garantie ne couvrirait pas votre
smartphone
on parle plus facilement de l'eau de
pluie d'éclaboussures enfin de choses de
la vie courante silva dans la piscine
center de los si vous avez vous lu
trempé pour nettoyer la garantie
s'appliquera pas et ça risque malgré
tout de l'endommager donc fait
extrêmement attention aux premières
choses qu'on ne fait pas on ne lit mais
rj pas pour nettoyer dans l'eau il ya
notre folie que l'on utilise beaucoup en
ce moment c'est ça c'est le gel
hydroalcoolique
on en est sûr des mains sèches la pique
de partout jusqu'à évaporation et là les
mains sont clean sauf que si vous le
faites sur vos smartphones et bien vous
êtes tout simplement le dézinguer ce
n'est pas fait pour ça c'est très très
très très agressif alors effectivement
ça va tuer les bactéries et les virus
sur vos smartphones mais pas que ça va
se situer les smartphones donc ne le
fait pas il ya juste une marque de
smartphones qui nous a dit la nasa n'a
conférence de presse qu'on pouvait
utiliser ça et justement pour rendre
leurs smartphones à usage professionnel
c'est cros col alors là j'ai la grosse
grosse grosse tablette c'est le cros
cole c'est le corps t4 que vous pourriez
selon ce que nous a dit françois
hollande fasse effectivement pour les
professionnels de santé venir nettoyer
avec un gel hydroalcoolique mais pour le
reste du monde pour le reste des
smartphones ne le fait absolument pas et
un autre produit qu'on a beaucoup chez
nous c'est ça c'est du nettoyant vitre
on s'en fiche de la maxe assez bien pour
nettoyer les carreaux mais ce n'est pas
du tout adapté pour venir nettoyer son
smartphone fait extrêmement attention ça
va forcément vous l'allumez tout de
suite ça peut vraiment vous l'endommager
dans le temps évitez vraiment de le
faire bien évidemment on va ne pas
utiliser tous ses produits nettoyants
pour la maison qui au temps
effectivement la javel ça va
probablement vous tuez le courant
n'avait russe sur une surface inerte sur
un un plan de travail sur une ce que
vous voulez mais par contre sur votre
smartphone vous allez aussi déglingué le
smartphone c'est très très agressif ne
pas utiliser de gel sans ou avec j'avais
et d'une manière générale ne peut
utiliser javed pour venir nettoyer vos
produits de la même manière il faut
vraiment éviter ça les lingettes multi
surfaces
quel que soit le lot quelle que soit la
marque ça va venir l'endommager il ya un
côté en plus abrasif qui va venir
vraiment vraiment abîmer votre écran
dont à proscrire
on va également éviter d'utiliser ses
mouchoirs qu'ils soient propres ou sales
dans tous les cas salle c'est vraiment
une très très mauvaise idée et puisqu'on
parle dans le côté un petit peu très
très très mauvaise idée
on va éviter d'utiliser sa salive alors
je ne sais pas s'ils savent où j'ai
passé par la tête mais je suis sûr que
c'est passé par tête de faire une
personne on n'utilise pas sa liste ce
n'est pas en
et on se pose en affectant en plus c'est
dégueulasse et en plus vous invitez
d'appuyer trop fort lorsque vous allez
venir nettoyer votre écran bon
maintenant que vous savez ce qu'il ne
faut pas faire d'ailleurs dit non aux
commentaires si vous vous avez fait ça
si vous avez utilisé ces différents
produits ces différentes techniques et
méthodes pour bien nettoyer votre
smartphone ou alors d'autres appareils à
la maison marquer le moindre commentaire
je serais très curieux de voir la
proportion de personnes qui lui ont fait
et si vous n'avez pas fait dit moi
quelles sont les astuces et qu'est ce
que vous faites pour venir nettoyer
votre smartphone
vos petits bugs vos airpod vos
compagnies et d'ailleurs est ce que vous
le faites
oui ou non ça c'est intéressant mce ii
mamba changement oblige pas les gens qui
l'ont pas fait on juge pas c'est
vraiment président se rend compte que
c'est extrêmement intéressant
la première chose à faire et ça c'est
d'une manière générale vous le savez
lorsque vous rentrez chez vous vous
allez vous laver les mains et c'est
exactement la même chose
moi ce que je vous conseille cd que vous
rentrez chez vous vous vous lavez les
mains et ensuite vous passer à la phase
de nettoyage de cette petite chose la
plus qu'une contamination s'est pas
gouttelettes mais également par zones de
contact donc si vous touchez le virus
mais potentiellement le transmettre d'un
objet à l'autre donc on fait attention
pour nettoyage efficace de ça vous avez
besoin de ça ou alors encore pourquoi
pas de ça une lingette ménagères on va
plutôt recommandé d'utiliser une petite
lingette qu'on va utiliser pour venir
nettoyer ses lunettes nettoyer un
objectif voyez c'est parfaitement
adaptée ça viendra parfaitement nettoyée
sans votre smartphone il faut bien
évidemment nettoyer mais pas uniquement
votre smartphone parce que imaginez que
vous avez eu les mains en contact avec
le corps navires us ou n'importe quel
virus de d une fois de plus soit de la
grippe et la gastro ou ce que vous
voulez vous avez donc des mains qui sont
potentiellement porteuses du virus
et ça surtout les doigts sur toutes les
différentes zones de votre main donc ça
veut dire que lorsque vous tenez votre
smartphone comme ça et bien votre écran
puisque vous naviguez dessus avec votre
devoir peuvent être potentiellement
contaminés mais également le dos du
smartphone serait quand même illogique
que vous ayez un seul doigt que soit
potentiellement contaminés et le reste
non ça veut donc dire qu'il faut venir
nettoyer l'intégralité de votre
smartphone alors ici j'ai une coque de
protection quelle que soit la coque de
protection que vous ayez il faut tout
nettoyer
de a à z la première chose que vous avez
fait une fois que vous êtes laver les
mains vous venez d faire les deux
parties dans un premier temps on va
commencer par les toyer la coque alors
pour la coke c'est extrêmement simple
vous vous embêtez pas vous mettez vos
mains vous les lavez voulaient s'abonner
bien vous prenez ça vous mettez du savon
dessus et vous venez tout savonner de
tous les côtés à l'intérieur à
l'extérieur les moindres recoins par
contre pensez bien à bien asséché
qu'elle soit vraiment sèche avant de la
remettre sur votre smartphone
bien évidemment ça c'est propre et ça
c'est sale
donc ce qu'il faut faire c'est prendre
et le mec dans un endroit qui est propre
avant qu'elle puisse rencontrer à
nouveau votre smartphone qui lui est
sale et qui potentiellement pourrait
être contaminé ensuite vous avez la
question de cette petite bête là oui
parce que potentiellement puisque vous
l'avez enlevé et si vous aviez les mains
sales et les mains contaminé vous
l'avais touché comme ça vous pouvez donc
potentiellement avoir des germes au dos
de votre smartphone
effectivement pour intérieur des lakers
à ses protégés non il faut donc tout
nettoyer faire extrêmement attention
vous pouvez utiliser trop bu pour
nettoyer alcool et le propre il y de
l'iso propanolol et ça ça marchera on va
donc fonctionner de la manière suivante
une grosse lingettes ici votre
smartphone et votre linge est ici de
l'iso propanolol vous prenez votre linge
est vous mettez les au propane dessus
vous prenez votre smartphone vous le
posez dessus
ensuite vous preniez votre linge est
vous prenez de l'alcool isopropylique
vous en mettez dessus et là vous venez
nettoyé de tous les côtés votre
smartphone sur la tranche sur le dessus
vous venez d toyer là vous nettoyez de
la même manière la face avant veillez à
ce que vos smartphones soit éteint
lorsque vous allez faire ces
manipulations vous nettoyer toutes les
surfaces de fond en comble pendant
plusieurs secondes pour vraiment tout
éradiquer tout nettoyer vous n'allez pas
détrempé complètement vos lingettes pour
ne pas détrempé votre smartphone et
voulu nettoyer wall street où les
surfaces tous les côtés le haut le bas
la droite le gauche l'avant l'arrière et
vous verrez que c'est pas ça quand même
plutôt bien une fois que vous êtes
arrivé ça vous mettez votre smartphone
de côté ça une fois que vous l'avez
utilisez vous le mettez en machine et
vous l'avez complètement forcément il
nous faut un petit stock de lingettes je
parle de ça de manière idéale après on
fait comme on peut avec ce qu'on a et
dans la possibilité de trop en faire
mais ça c'est un petit peu le cas idéal
de la même manière à ce que vous allez
faire ces manipulations vous avez pas
besoin de gants un bon lavage de mains
une femme j'ai fait tout ça suffira
largement si vous avez bien nettoyer vos
buzz ou écouteurs c'est exactement la
même chose vous pourriez dans la
lingette vous le frottez et ça vous le
fait systématiquement lorsque vous
rentrez chez vous par contre pour un
ordinateur portable et on fait la même
chose avec une lingette sur l'extérieur
et surtout les contours du produit vous
prenez des cotons tiges avec le même
alcool que josé spécifie avant et vous
venez nettoyer entre les touches vous
nettoyez clavier bien évidemment il faut
que tous vos produits électroniques soit
éteint à ce moment là sans rentrer dans
les extrêmes et dans les excès je pense
que quand vous rentrez chez vous il faut
que vous nettoyez systématiquement tous
les produits qui arrivent de l'extérieur
sur la vie courante de la vie normale
hors période effectivement de couronnes
un virus fait pas ça vous rentrerez dans
une paranoïa du tout propre chez vous
les par contre aujourd'hui avec ce qui
se passe avec le corona virus je pense
que
vous rentrez chez vous ça me paraît très
important de venir nettoyer tout ce qui
arrive de l'extérieur d'avoir vraiment
une zone salle est une ville propre
ça c'est votre maison du moins c'est le
plan de la maison on imagine ici qu'on
va voir l'entrée principale gens ça
regarde on peut avoir un hall d'entrée
ici et ensuite vous dispatchez ça peut
être sur un salon des chambres ce que
vous voulez ça c'est votre maison au
chant de salon cuisine j'en sais
absolument rien par contre ce qui est
sûr c'est que tout ce qui entre ici
c'est sale ça veut dire que
potentiellement ça peut être contaminé
faut pas être paranoïaque mais
potentiellement ils font réfléchir comme
ça donc ici c'est une bonne salle
c'est à dire que vous allez stocké ici
vos chaussures vos vestes tout ce qui
vient de l'extérieur que vous avez va
pouvoir nettoyer chaque fois par contre
ça c'est uniquement la zone salle tout
le reste de votre maison constitue la
zone propre et cette zone propre il faut
vraiment veiller à ce qu'elle reste
c'est à dire que dès que vous rentrez
chez vous vous vous déchausser vous
enlevez votre veste vous allez tout de
suite vous laver les mains est un fait
vous passez au lavage de ce qui vient de
l'extérieur et notamment de votre
smartphone pour inviter d'emmener les
germes que vous auriez extérieur
n'attendez pas d'avoir été faire je ne
sais quoi chez vous d'avoir posé
smartphones de la vente des places à
droite et à gauche pour ensuite faire ça
si toutefois il y avait des gens dessus
vous pourriez les disséminer et la saga
bâtiment m sans rentrer une fois de plus
dans une paranoïa globale de se dire du
tout propre et de se dire attention j'ai
mis des virus partout pensez vraiment à
nettoyer une fois de plus il faut
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment ne
pas rentrer à côté paranoïaque en dix
ans j'étais en contact avec d'autres
êtres humains ils sont potentiellement
infectées je pourrais l'avoir en fin de
période d'incubation c'est foutrement
rien ne rentrait pas dans les extrêmes
mais pendant cette période mettez en
place des petits procès ce qu'ils
peuvent aussi venir vous aider
on ne sera pas aussi efficace que le
fait de rester confinés chez soi et de
bord personnel parle à personne mais si
toutefois vous deviez à l'extérieur pour
une raison ou pour une autre
je pense qu'un petit geste comme ça
qu'il prend pas beaucoup de temps ne
peut porter qu'un plus et de manière
globale ça me paraît assez bien pensé
aussi à venir passer un petit coup de
lingette avec de la javel francou sur
les interrupteurs sur les poignets ça
mange pas de pain voilà on s'en arrête
là pour aujourd'hui j'espère que ça vous
aura donné quelques éléments de réponse
quelques informations sur ce qu'il faut
faire et pas faire d'une manière globale
d'une manière générale déjà une chose
que sur les produits utilisés pour venir
nettoyer votre smartphone et vos objets
à la maison et que ça pourra vous aider
dans ce cas épidémique aujourd'hui qui
est très compliqué j'espère que vous
vous portez bien que vous
et vos proches allaient bien et rassurez
vous on viendra à bout de ce virus d'ici
quelques temps dont on fait gaffe on
reste chez nous on respecte les gestes
sont donnés par le gouvernement est dans
l'absolu ça devrait bien se passer
je vous embrasse pour les soins du monde
à demain
[Applaudissements]
m
dans ce schéma
us
[Musique]